all right time for goats in a bad way
chris coming out of week nine i've got a
trivia question for you
mike tomlin now has 14 consecutive
non-losing seasons to begin his career
that
ties him for the most consecutive
non-losing seasons with which coach
hmm i i i
saw this recently and i just can't
remember where i
marty schottenheimer ding there you go
it was on your website
i believe i read that on your website at
some point here in the last year that's
that's one of the tests to see if you
number one visit my
website and number two if you can read
so you pass both
i can barely yes i did it thank you very
much
um all right you're up okay
i think i have to go with the detroit
lions
and their defense okay and specifically
to that i just want to make sure i get
the yardage right stop my sneeze
got my sneeze on camera good i'm glad
you got we got i had to sneeze i
couldn't fight it off but specifically
the 70-yard run by dalvin cook
to have 10 people on the football field
i mean that's just not
acceptable so to me goats in a bad way
right off the bat i'm gonna go with the
lions defense matt patricia
anybody responsible for that debacle you
know the game at that point it's 27-13
it's not totally crazy out of reach
anything like that
and yet we don't have a guy at the end
of the line of scrimmage and one of the
biggest
first plays of the drive of the of the
game i mean if you want a chance to come
back and win the game
and we don't even put 11 guys out there
man that was a bad one so they got to
take the cake there
yeah the lions are 2 and 13 in the
division under matt patricia that is not
going to keep patricia or gm bob quinn
employed it wasn't that long ago that we
were feeling good about the lions right
they were buyers
right as the trade deadline approached
getting everson griffin
but uh now not and it feels like it's
going the wrong way for the lions who
are at three and five
and uh uh they better win some games
quickly or there will be some major
changes in detroit first one for me i'm
surprised you left him on the
i know it's gotta it's gotta be tommy
well i know you know what i didn't want
to give bruce aryan i didn't want to
give bruce aries any credit i just i
didn't want to hear it that's honestly
why i did it i was like you know what we
talked about brady
and i just went against it i know but
it's still the goats it's these are the
goats of the week
prime time brady's got a prime time
problem this year
maybe it's a buccaneers maybe it's a but
hey i don't know staying up too late
getting a little too old get a little
it sounds like you're cousins he's got a
prime time problem
well but but it i mean it is look they
they lose to the bears
with that lost track of kirk cousins
never loses track of what down it is
he can't do anything about it but he
hasn't lost track of what down it is
uh you've got that you've got the giants
game that they barely won and could have
lost maybe should have lost and then the
blowout
so it's got to be brady three
interceptions it's on him he's the
leader of this team
he's the guy that wanted a b there and
the first night when they get the
opportunity
to settle the score with the saints to
pull into the driver's seat in the nfc
south it blows up in their faces and now
they have to worry about not making the
playoffs at all
yeah no it i mean it's it's gonna be a
struggle here now we're gonna see i mean
of course we know they got some tough
football games left and
they're really behind the eight ball as
far as winning the division
or maybe trying to be that one seed
that's that's definitely not happening
so i hear you there that's not a bad
pick
um i mean it's a good pick i i get you
man there's a lot to pick from here i'm
having a hard time figuring out which
one i think i gotta go with the seattle
seahawks defense though
maybe i'm just gonna say ken norton and
pete carroll that's what i'm gonna say
you know yes i mean buffalo was smart
they threw the ball
every freaking play that's right why
would they run it on you seattle
why what you have a good run defense
your pass offense is historically
horrible
right so you know what the hell are we
doing over there
it just it looks so bad on seattle's
defense i don't know what to say
little details that are not coached
right you know there's just
issues every week across the board let
alone i know the talent is not great
there
but it's not as bad as what their
statistics are saying
so there there is issues there and on
that point too
you know alan went 31 to 38
again i'm just glad he shut some people
up all right i mean i
thought you can't fix accuracy didn't
think you could fix it
oh that's right he's accurate again all
right either way
everybody get off josh allen's back shut
the hell up he's still one of the five
best quarterbacks in football
okay how do you get that off my chest
you jim you're you're jamming hey you're
jamming a lot of guys
top five today you've already claimed
two spots dak prescott and josh
i said dak prescott was top eight i
didn't say he was top five
you said five or six i said he was six i
think at first and then i said he's
definitely in the top eight
all right thank you counselor all right
uh am i up now yeah well usually after
me
you go yes i got i lost track of my
notes
uh next one for me
i got to go zane gonzalez the cardinals
kicker um there was a time
when when they used to kick straight on
where
it was fairly impressive to make a
40-yard field vote
and a 50-yarder was unheard of at some
point in the past
45 years the 40 yarder became a chip
shot and the 50 yarder became not quite
automatic
but not as big of a deal as it used to
be i just remember like in the 80s
if it was 45 46 47 you never quite knew
whether or not the guy was going to get
it there whether he's going to be able
to keep it
between the goal post because he has to
put all of his leg into it
and that's a no b that's no big deal
anymore 49 49 yarder no no big deal the
only question about that is whether or
not it's going to go left or right zayn
gonzalez to force overtime
in that classic cardinals dolphins game
between
kyler and tua he comes up short yeah
that's amazing who comes up short right
on a 49-yard field goal in today's nfl
chris
i can't remember the last time i saw
that no i i mean
and what's weird is it doesn't look like
anything was hit
wrong and even you read read his lips
after he missed it
he's talking to the holder and he goes i
don't know what happened like he's you
could really see him say that so
i don't know either you're right but 49
yards this day and age
is nothing for these guys i mean what is
it it's not like you're trying to put
the ball on the green and you left a
little bit like you you don't
you don't need to take something off of
it well we saw the guy off of it you
don't need to take any off of it just
kill the damn thing
no that's what's amazing we saw the guy
in carolina right against the kansas
city
they attempted what was that a 67 yarder
and it had been long enough it did i
know that's what's amazing so
yeah i'm with you i'm shocked um all
right
i hate to do this because there was so
many positives
no you don't well i i think the biggest
blunder of the week
it's either between i mean i i could
certainly talk about flacco and some of
the crap he did last night
matt nagy i mean they could be on the
list every week for their offense i mean
really we should just put them in a
traditional spot make him the fourth
pick
every week then i think the one i gotta
go to
is the dallas cowboys it's third and
five it's 1950. it's 1915.
okay we're on the five yard line garrett
gilbert your quarterback
it's the pittsburgh freaking steelers
defense who just turned over lamar
jackson last week
and all that stuff and you got gallaudet
garrett gilbert
not lamar jackson and he hasn't played a
lot of football let alone nfl football
it's the steelers once again i just
wanted to say that oh wait guess what
happened
the steelers got pressure and hit him as
he was throwing
ball pops in the air interception there
goes the chip shot field goal to go up
by a touchdown
and really make it tough on pittsburgh i
mean to me
when you talk about managing a game and
doing things a certain way
that risk reward was just not worth it
against that defense with your
quarterback and
that's one that stood out to me last one
for me
and i hate to do this but i'm gonna do
it anyway i'm gonna preface it the way
you did i'm doing it yes i am
brent boyer the jet special teams
coordinator because even though it
wasn't
fatal last night how in the hell do you
send 12 guys out for a field goal block
how's that i mean that could have been
faded how does that happen yeah how does
it happen
right you've got your field goal team
and there are 11 guys on it how in the
hell do 12 get
sent out i can understand it for an
offense and
things a little complicated defense what
package are we using there's no
sub package for a field goal try you've
got 11 guys
you send them out how in the hell does
the 12th guy
make his way onto the field and if they
had a touchdown on that drive that would
have been way worse he got lucky that
they ended up still settling for a field
goal but you're right that's just
that's an 0-9 football team for you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports